you
three years ago many banana farmers on
st. Lucia lost everything hurricane
tomas destroyed their fields Giuliana &
Albert satiny had to take out a 10,000
u.s. dollar bank loan today they can
harvest bananas again their plants yield
fruit all year round but the couple
aren't earning enough from their farm
they're barely scraping by when I pit up
but I sin what artists in photo credit
union I have to pay my bills and their
little you remain you have to try to
survive with it she's had to prevent
that from happening again after the next
storm the United Nations University has
come up with a hurricane Insurance
Scheme project manager Subbaiah Becker
is working with local insurer EC global
which will sell the policy the idea
behind it is simple a policy costs 80
east caribbean dollars per year when a
hurricane hits the insurer will pay
policyholders 1,000 east caribbean
dollars regardless of whether the storm
has done any damage an independent
weather station measures rain and wind
speed it's an unusual idea and at first
it was hard for banker to win over and
insurer you know any time you went to an
insurance said well you know
there-there's there doesn't have to be
real proof of damage but if wind and
rain speeds exceed certain certain
threshold limits there will be an
automatic payout obviously this was a
completely new concept and it was
difficult for first of all the insurers
to come to grip with it there no
hurricanes then we benefit but when the
disaster comes we also have to pay out a
significant amount of money so there's a
potential there too to me money there's
a potential there to lose money we never
know what what the extent of the
catastrophe will be how bad it will be
all severe to learn yeah proponents have
to convince locals to hear in the
village of dennery on the Atlantic coast
they're putting on a play to explain the
insurance scheme everyone here knows
what a big hurricane means residents
were hit very hard by the last
apical storm 30 minutes later the show
is over and the party has just begun
some people have already decided to buy
the plan
if you give me the forms right now so
that I could feel right now eighty
dollars are gonna feel for many years
because i cannot get an insurance in
santa lucia at this woman to ensure my
business on a different in general in
the days after the show more people in
dennery up to purchase the policy people
here don't want to lose everything as
they did three years ago